[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: Let me
remind you from the reading
list where we are.
We did the introductory
lecture, of course,
about economic science.
And last time, we did our
first nuts and bolts lecture
on preferences, consumer theory,
with the associated starred
readings.
And today, we're
going to do more
the way we ended the last
class on consumer behavior.
I'm showing this reading
list because I just
want to remind you that these
starred articles do exist.
The Nicholson and
Schneider chapter 5,
from which this is drawn,
although not entirely.
And also, this Jensen
and Miller paper,
which I will say a few words
about today because it fits
into this lecture, but
also, as I probably
mentioned too many
times, that's also
a big part of your first
problem set and involves
getting that paper, reading the
yellow markings as highlights,
accessing the data
that these guys used,
and running through some
of their calculations.
So that's the part of
the starred readings
for this lecture.
So in terms of the study
guide, Consumer Theory,
as I was alerting you
last time, there's
a pretty good thorough review
of what you should have learned
or are learning from
the topic of last time.
And I will not go
through all of this,
but I will ask a
few questions, get
a few volunteers, maybe even
call on a couple of you.
So this one, give a plausible
example of a commodity point
that could not be in a
typical consumption set.
And I'll take
volunteers on that.
It's partly remembering
the slide where I showed
examples of consumption sets.
Does anyone remember?
The question is-- yes?
AUDIENCE: One infeasible
consumption site
is consuming 25 hours in a
day or something like that.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: That's good.
Yep, that was one of
the diagrams where
the amount of leisure
available for work or leisure,
the sum could not exceed 25.
There was another one,
which you might not
have thought of given
the way this is worded,
which is consumption of
bread in New York at noon
and consumption in
Boston at noon of bread.
And you're not allowed to
have bread in the interior
because you can't
consume simultaneously
in both New York and Boston.
So that was another example.
But your answer was great.
So can someone
volunteer to give me
the definition of
local non-satiation?
AUDIENCE: That
means that there's
in that-- so if you have a
bundle, in any neighborhood
of that bundle, there is
some other bundle that's
preferred to the bundle
you originally had.
There are no bliss points.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND:
That's right.
That's an excellent answer.
Yeah, I can't remember
whether we did X or Y.
But for any X in
the consumption set,
there's some other Y,
no matter how close
we are to X, which is
preferred to X and-- well,
and Y has to be in
the consumption set.
So both things have to be true.
It has to be available in this
little ball or circle around X,
and it has to be preferred.
And you gave a good
counter-example.
If there were a
bliss point, that
means there's something
that is maximal utility
among all possible points.
So if we do a
circle around that,
everything else
would be inferior.
If you went beyond the bliss
point, northeast of it,
you have too much
of all the goods.
But then, ironically, you
also have local non-satiation
because, given any point X,
there's another point Y, which
involves less than both goods.
That would be strictly
preferred because you're
moving to the bliss point.
So anyway, the point of
this little discussion
is that local non-satiation
and global non-satiation
are two different things.
Thank you.
OK, let's-- what does it mean
for a preference relation to be
represented by a
utility function?
Given a preference
relation, is the utility
function that
represents it unique?
Yes or no, and explain.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so we say that
a utility function represents
a preference if, for example,
for any consumption bundle, X,
any two consumption bundles, X
and Y, if X is preferred to Y,
then U of X is
greater than U of Y.
And the utility
function is not unique.
It just has to respect the given
ordering of the preferences.
So we could have U, or
U squared, or U cubed,
and all of those would work.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: Excellent.
Perfect answer.
Any other comments or
questions about that?
AUDIENCE: I had a question.
On this slide, it
had said that it
was unique only up to an order
preserving transformation.
What exactly does
that, I guess, mean?
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: Well,
if you had three points,
ordering them from
low to high in terms
of preference relation--
say, X1, X2, X3, where
X3 is preferred to X2
is preferred to X1,
all we need to do
is to assign a higher number
to the best one, a lower number
to the intermediate one.
So something like 15, 5, 1
preserves the rank ordering.
Those are utility
number assignments.
But we could multiply by 2,
and then we have 30, 10, 2.
But we're still assigning
numbers from high to low
to preserve the
same rank ordering.
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank you.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: OK.
Yes, go on.
AUDIENCE: Do you eventually
need to, I guess,
reintroduce some
concept of magnitude--
or not magnitude,
but have something
beyond just ordering if you want
to start talking about gambling
or expected value?
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND:
Yes, absolutely.
And we're going to do
that in two lectures.
So there, the utility
function will--
the ordinal
representation matters.
And the question will be, how
much more utility do you get
or how much less, depending
on an adverse event?
So that the curvature literally
represents your willingness
to take gambles.
Whereas with an
ordinal function,
a linear function is fine.
Linear function
when you're facing
gambles means
you're risk-neutral,
and you just rank based
on expected values.
That's all a little bit early.
It's a great question.
And we're going to get
there in two lectures.
We got time for one more here.
What does it mean for
preferences to be homothetic?
AUDIENCE: The MRS is just
depending on the ratio
of two goods, right?
Not depending on the absolute
quantity of each good.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND:
Yep, perfect.
Wow, I'm very happy,
very impressed.
Thank you, all.
That's tremendous.
OK, so again, these are just
somewhat randomly selected.
I do go over these
before class to help
me decide, since I
can't ask them all,
which one I would ask in class.
There are some of these
that say draw a graph
or so on and so forth.
So I didn't ask about those.
But none of them are
supposed to be terribly hard.
But it is always a good
review, at a minimum.
OK, so today is a lecture
on income and substitution
effects.
Or really, it's about
consumer-maximizing behavior.
And so when we solve the
consumers utility maximization
problem, we get individual
demand functions.
It should say function
with an S because if there
are n goods, little n, then
there's a demand for good 1,
good 2, good n, and so on.
And what are the arguments
in these demand functions?
The entire vector of
Prices, denoted P1
through Pn, and
Income, denoted as I.
And you can think about
prices and income denominated
in dollars or some
unit of account.
We're going to be
spending time looking
at how the price of
good k changes when
we change the price of good k.
But of necessity, other goods
will be changing as well.
It's at best, the implicit
happenings in the diagrams.
So here is a little
bit of a repeat
but expanded from last time.
We've got two goods
denoted, X and Y.
And this household has a certain
amount of income, I, say, I2.
If income were I2,
to this would be
the budget line, which has
a slope of PX over PY minus.
And this is the tangency which
is the maximum utility point
denoted X2,Y2, associated
with income I2.
What this diagram is
featuring, though,
is not a single maximization.
It's how the maximization point
changes if you increase income.
So you would move from
X2,Y2 to X3,Y3, for example.
And likewise, if your
income were less,
if this household's income were
less, they would move to Y1,X1.
So you could connect these dots.
And as only income is
varying and the price ratio
is held fixed, we could
call the connected dots
an income expansion path.
And I'll show you some
examples of that momentarily.
Here is a different experiment.
Did we miss something?
Well, in this one,
you'll get lulled
into thinking that,
as income changes,
the amount spent on both
goods has to change, increase.
But that's not
necessarily the case.
So here, again, we're
going from I1 to I2 to I3
and tracing out the quantities
from ZY1, ZY2 to ZY3.
And here, the quantity demanded
of good Y is increasing,
but the quantity demanded of
good Z is actually decreasing.
So there's nothing terribly
peculiar about the shape
of these indifference curves.
We didn't have to struggle too
hard to get this phenomenon
to happen.
But anyway, this
phenomenon has a name.
Namely, the good Y over here
would be called a normal good,
and good Z would be called an
inferior good or a necessity
because the amount
that you consume of it
diminishes as income goes up.
So here are those
definitions, a good
for which the demand
of good i goes down
as income-- capital I-- goes up
is said to be an inferior good.
It doesn't have to happen over
the entire range of income
and prices.
But if it happens locally,
it's called an inferior good
locally.
And likewise, if the derivative
with respect to income
is positive, then we
call, in some range,
the good to be a normal
good or noninferior good.
So there's something
called Engel's Law.
And with the caveat that
this is not one household,
it's actually comparing
across households that
differ in their annual income.
So here, we're going from
an annual income of $225
to-- this is written
in 1920, by the way.
Don't be too alarmed.
There's been a lot of inflation.
So this, in real
purchasing power,
was more than you
thought, $300--
or this range, 450 to
600 or 750 to 1,000.
And what you can
see is the percent
spent of the budget
on food declines
as we move to
these income groups
with higher and higher income.
So in some sense, if all
consumers were alike,
and some had more
income than others,
we'd be looking at what an
individual household would
do as its income changed.
And in this case, food
would be an inferior good.
You're saying, what's going up?
Clothing, not by much.
Lodging, not at all.
What really expands
as income goes up
is services, education, health,
legal, and other services.
In fact, in the US
economy, looking
over decades, the fraction
of services produced in GDP
just keeps going
up, and up, and up,
which is reflective of the
fact that, as households
have more income, they demand
more services than less food.
So that's pretty dated, 1920.
So I went on the web and looked
this thing up, Engel's Law
today.
Here, we're dividing
households into quintiles,
five groups, an equal number
of households in each group.
And we plot the fraction
of so-called luxuries
and necessities for each group.
Now, this is a bit
problematic in the sense
that necessities are
defined as goods or services
where consumption is
proportionately lower
as a person's income increases.
So again, necessity
or non-normal goods
or as we defined it in
the last three slides.
Not too surprisingly, the
highest income groups,
the top 20% of the population,
the proportion of expenditure
on luxuries is a lot
higher than on necessities.
And that gap lowers
until you get
to the lowest group,
in which case,
the fraction spent
on necessities
is a lot higher than luxuries.
Now, when I grabbed this,
there was an whole article
about how poor people
are extravagant
because they're still spending
money on luxury goods.
Well, I mean, narrowly
speaking, yes, that's true.
But again, it's a
little bit harsh
because it doesn't mean
they're driving around
in a Mercedes Benz.
It just means they're
eating some fraction of what
they spend on are normal goods.
AUDIENCE: Wait.
Can you-- is there a little bit
of issue with how those two--
I guess, how the two
lines are defined?
Because the way
you defined them,
it seems like you said luxuries
are just what rich people buy,
and necessities are
what poor people buy.
So doesn't this kind
of get confirmed just
by how you define it?
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: Yes, I
think that's exactly right.
It's almost tautological.
I mean, the way
they defined it, it
has to be true that this blue
line is going up and up as you
go across the quantiles.
So I agree with that comment.
But I still think the graphs--
how much is it going up,
what's the difference,
and so on, could go up
just a teeny little bit,
in which case, that blue
line would not move much.
Other questions?
Well, one takeaway from
this is different households
that differ in income do
not spend the same fraction
of their money on goods.
So let me take a
chance at the risk of--
preview of coming
attractions, this
is way back in lecture
18, where we're
going to talk about aggregation,
which has to do with whether we
can represent demand
functions as if they came
from a single maximizing
representative
household or weaker, that
there is a group of households,
like the lower quintile,
and they're all alike.
And we could take a
representative low-quintile
household and talk
about the demand
as if it were coming
from that one person.
What is a necessary and
sufficient assumption
for us to be able to do
that kind of aggregation?
It is that these income--
in this case, denoted
wealth expansion paths--
are linear and have
exactly the same slope.
So these guys will spend--
and I'm not trying to go
through the entire lecture.
I'm just really
trying to motivate you
that we looked at
some micro data,
and later, we'll make
some assumptions.
It's good to put the microdata
about the assumptions
on the table at the same
time and compare them.
What's going on here is that,
if these income expansion
paths are parallel, then
when we increase income
for one household, it's
expenditure would go up.
But because this
line is parallel,
when we decrease
expenditure for another one,
it's expenditures will go down
in exactly the same amount
that this guy's went up.
So those income effects
are completely offsetting.
And that turns out to be
necessary and sufficient to add
up all of income
and drive demand
as if we've given all of
income to one household.
All right.
Well, it was with
some trepidation
that I showed you
this picture, but I
thought you might like
to know what's coming.
And we'll review all of
that when we get to 18.
OK, so let's talk about income
and substitution effects now.
Instead of changing income,
we want to change a price.
We're going to focus on
good X. We're going to look
at an initial point,
which is Y*,X*.
And then we're going to
lower the price of good X
and not touch good Y.
One way to quickly
convince yourself
that the diagram is correct
is that this point over here
on the Y-axis is
taking all your income
and devoting it to the purchase
of good Y. The price of Y
hasn't changed, so this
point hasn't changed.
But the price of
X is going down.
And logically, the set of
things you can buy is expanding.
So this budget line
shifts to the right,
but not in a parallel fashion.
So what is the new purchase?
The new purchase is a
tangency, Y** and X**.
And we're going to break that
movement from the initial point
to the subsequent
point into two pieces--
one, a price effect, and
two, an income effect.
So since the price
of good X goes down,
PX over PY in absolute
value is going down.
So there's a new budget
line with a lower
slope that is pivoting on the
initial indifference curve, U1.
So setting aside income effects,
which we'll get to momentarily,
the natural impact of
lowering the price of good X
is to increase the
expenditure of good X
and decrease the
expenditure of good Y.
So that's called the
substitution effect.
And it's a movement from X*,Y*
to B. But in fact, of course,
income--
effectively, purchasing
power has gone up.
Even though nominal income has
not moved, one good, at least,
is cheaper.
So their effect of
income has gone up,
and that's represented by
this parallel shift from B
to X**,Y**.
And that last bit
from B to there
is called the income effect.
So the global movement is from
X* to X** with a corresponding
movement from Y* to Y**.
And it's broken into two pieces,
this substitution effect, which
corresponds with movement
along the original indifference
curve, and the income
effect of having higher
effective purchasing power.
OK?
A lot of today's
lecture is just going
over this in various ways.
You can get mesmerized
with the price decrease.
Here is a price increase.
They're starting
out with a tangency.
The price of good X still
goes, in this case, up.
Their purchasing
power goes down.
The budget line rotates from
this initial point, inward.
So the total demand of the
price increase is going down,
a reduction in X.
But again, we can break
that into two pieces.
One is a substitution effect,
the movement away from good X--
because it has a higher
price relative to good Y--
to point B. And now
we take into account
the loss of effective
purchasing power, which
is a shift in this budget line,
the dotted tangency line, which
is tangent at B, to the
actual new, lower budget line.
So here, we denote the
combination of the substitution
and income effect.
This is really the previous
diagram in reverse.
But I think it's
useful to show both.
Of course, we can also start
changing the price of Y. Let's
not do that right away.
I'll come back to that later.
But the principles
remain the same.
So let's construct
some demand curves,
as in the equation
system we had initially.
If we keep lowering the price,
moving in this direction,
we trace out this tangency.
And those will be the demand
at the associated prices.
So here, we have,
say, X prime at price,
P prime, X double prime
at price P double prime--
and this would have
been even better
if these things were lined up
as they were intended to be--
X triple prime at
price P triple prime.
Now, again, price is going
down, and demand is going up.
Now, just to alert
you, I don't know
where this got started,
with Marshall or whatever.
But usually, we plot Y
is a function of X, where
X is on the Y-axis, and
Y, the dependent variable,
is on the Y-axis.
This is actually
plotted in reverse
because we're varying price
as an exogenous variable
and plotting the demand.
No big deal.
I don't think I can
plot it the other way.
Actually, I could.
But you'll see why
this can get confusing.
I just thought I'd point
it out along the way.
OK.
Now we come to Giffen's Paradox.
If the income effect of a
price change is strong enough,
the change in the price
and the resulting change
in the quantity
demanded could actually
move in the same direction.
So let me give you
an example that's
attributed to Robert
Giffen, who claimed
to observe this in Ireland,
where they had a famine.
So the potato crop was failing,
and the price of potatoes
was rising.
And despite the rise in
price, people consumed more.
So the demand curve
was upward-sloping, not
downward-sloping.
His explanation was, potatoes
are a big part of the budget.
When their price goes up, the
effect of income goes down.
And that income
effect dominates.
The lower income effect is what
lowers the demand for the good.
But in effect, prices
go up, and demand goes--
well, income's going down.
But this good is a necessity.
So you get a negative
sign on the income effect,
so the demand is going up.
So price and income are
going up at the same time.
It's a bit of a mouthful.
No pun intended.
Actually, this could
not have happened.
It would require
that potatoes be
an important part of the budget,
that potatoes be a necessity.
But what doesn't fit the facts
is, how are they consuming more
potatoes when, in fact,
there was a blight,
and there were no more
potatoes to be had?
So something doesn't
add up, literally.
Anyway, all intermediate
micro classes
typically feature Giffen
goods and then move on.
And you may be left
wondering if it ever
really happens in practice.
So searching around, I
discovered Jensen and Miller,
who actually ran an experiment.
So this is literally a
randomized controlled trial.
They went to China, two
different provinces,
looked at relatively
poor households,
and changed the price of
the staple food item that
was a big part of their budget.
Now, in order to
make the comparison,
you've got to change the price.
So it was a randomized
controlled trial,
meaning, randomly, some
households were exposed
to a lower price because
they were given vouchers
so that when they
went to the store,
the sum of U unpaid
plus vouchers
equaled the stated price.
But they didn't have to
pay for the vouchers.
So effectively, from
their point of view,
the price was lowered,
given the vouchers.
And the control group
did not receive vouchers.
So the control group faced
the normal market price.
And what Jensen and
Miller are doing
is comparing the control group
with the treatment group.
And what they discovered
was, in Hunan, in the South,
rice was the staple good.
In Guangzhou, it's wheat.
They did surveys,
like Engel, before,
during, and after the subsidy
on both treatment and control
groups.
And they found strong evidence
that poor households in Hunan
experienced this Giffen
behavior with respect to rice.
That is to say, when the
price of rice went down,
households reduced
their demand for rice.
The evidence was mixed
in the other province.
And I think I will choose not
to say very much about this.
There were groups, the very
poorest and the least poor
that responded in what you might
think to be the ordinary way,
with price--
with demand down-sloping.
But there was a group in the
middle between the very poorest
and the least poor which
exhibited Giffen behavior.
As it's written on the slide,
this is a bit of a mystery.
Why is it that we're
getting this difference
across the three groups,
or two groups plus one?
And I leave that for you
because, again, the problem set
features the entire article.
We try to make it easy
by highlighting the text.
But somewhere in that
paper is a discussion
of why this result, which is
a bit hard to interpret here,
does happen.
The authors did give
it an interpretation.
So that's advertising to go
and grab that paper, which
I think I already have.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so is the
demand the amount of potatoes
or rice you're consuming,
or the proportion
that is of your income
that's increasing?
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND:
It's the quantity.
But obviously, they
have the prices.
So you can look at both.
But the definition we've been
using of a Giffen good, it's--
well, actually, it never showed.
But it is the quantity-- in this
case, the quantity of potatoes,
not expenditure on potatoes.
All right.
OK, so now I want to get
to something, effectively,
we've already been doing,
which is compensated
versus uncompensated demands.
So the uncompensated
demand is the total demand,
sometimes called the Marshallian
demand from Marshall,
who was an early
English economist.
It shows the relationship
between price of the good
and the quantity purchased,
assuming that all other prices
and income are held constant.
The compensated demand,
sometimes called the Hicksian
demand, shows the relationship
between price and quantity.
It continues to assume that
all the other prices are
held fixed.
But instead of holding income
fixed, utility is held fixed.
So to go back to
the earlier slides,
we were featuring the
substitution effect
as the movement along
an indifference curve--
i.e., holding utility fixed.
So when we looked at how
much demand would change
one way or the other as a
function of the price change,
and we went along the initial
baseline indifference curve,
that was the compensated demand.
So more dramatically, if
we fix the initial point
and change the price, we
would be, for a lower price,
pivoting along this
indifference curve, U2.
By construction, we keep
utility constant at U2.
And then plot the demands,
which are going up,
and we put that on the
price quantity diagram,
and the demand curve
is sloping down.
But this is the Hicksian
demand at little h
to remind us that it's Hicks.
So putting both types of
demand on the same diagram,
we'd have the normal demand,
or the Marshallian demand,
and h for the Hicksian demand.
So as price goes
down, demand goes up,
but the demand goes up
from two different effects.
One is the substitution effect
holding utility constant,
and that's a point on
the Hicksian demand.
And then the rest of it is this
movement to the Marshallian
demand, or ordinary demand,
which is the income effect that
comes from the lower price.
And obviously, we can go
in the other direction.
Starting here as a baseline,
if we increase the price,
we would pivot along
the indifference curve
and get a lower demand due
to the substitution effect.
But effective income
has gone down,
so this negative
income effect kicks in,
and demand is even less.
So kind of intuitively,
the Hicksian demand
is steeper than the
ordinary demand curve
because it has included
those income effects.
Or putting in another way,
the ordinary demand curve
is, quote, flatter
with a lower slope
because there's a more dramatic
larger change in the quantity
as we change the price.
Either the income
effect is positive,
and demand goes up all
the more, or the income
effect is negative, and the
demand decreases all the more.
So we could say-- be
careful about this--
that, in some sense,
the ordinary demand
curve is more elastic.
At least here, it has
a higher derivative.
So there's a
mathematical expression
for the difference between
the Hicksian demand
and the ordinary demand.
Namely, the derivative
of demand of good X
as we change the price of X,
the slope of the ordinary demand
curve, is first term,
the substitution effect
of the price change, PX,
but then this income effect
kicks in.
And there's two pieces
to the income effect.
One has to do with how high
is the marginal change in X
as you change income.
The other is, how much X you
were eating to begin with.
Think of potatoes, and
so on, or those budget
shares, either Engel
or-- but this is X.
This is the quantity.
So it looks, from this, since
we're subtracting-- say,
the income effect is
positive, and X is positive.
Then we're subtracting
a positive number.
So it looks like this minus
this must be lower than this.
So it looks like
the ordinary demand
should have a lower slope if
this equation is accurate.
But in fact, as I just said,
it's the other way around.
Puzzle, puzzle, puzzle.
What's going on?
Well, it's this stupid
way that we traditionally
plot the dependent
variable on the X-axis.
So this is dX/dP, the response
of the dependent variable
to the independent
variable, which
is 1 over the slope of this.
So this diagram is consistent
with this equation.
It just takes a little bit
of juggling to realize why.
Anyway, this is called
Slutsky's equation.
And again, at the risk of
trying to do too much too
fast, but on the
other hand, providing
some motivation for
where we're going,
eventually, we'll get to
lecture 19 and talk about
whether there are retractable
restrictions on data, as
in the science lecture.
We have a model.
Does the model fit
the data or not?
Can you even reject the model?
Is it providing some guidance?
Or you can always tweak things,
so the model is always true.
So this lecture 19
is about restrictions
that can be tested.
And there's something
called Slutsky, same guy,
Slutsky's Decomposition
this equation is
a generalization of the
one I was just showing you,
with the exception that
we put this substitution
effect on the left and
the regular derivative
on the right.
So it looks like the
signs are changing.
This becomes a plus.
This is a generalization
in a number of respects.
We're looking at the
demand for good L
as we change the price of
another good, good K, not
the own effect of one good
with respect to its own price,
but a cross-partial derivative.
Although we still have this
income effect over here,
and we're still weighting it by
the initial quantity purchased.
So it turns out that
what we want to do
is ask whether observe demands--
this guy, these guys, really--
how demand is changing
with prices and income,
whether there are patterns
which could be rejected as being
inconsistent with a model.
And the problem is
that the restrictions
are on these Hicksian demands,
and we don't see those.
We see the regular demands.
We don't see the
Hicksian demands.
And I'll say more
about this in a minute.
It turns out that,
with some math,
you can actually
go back and forth
between the regular demand
and the Hicksian in demand,
and there are restrictions.
So anyway, I'm
running an experiment
now because I'm
showing you things
that are more toward
the end of the class
set of lectures than
at the beginning.
But since we're introducing
Slutsky's equation today,
I thought I'd show you that
we will come back to it
and use it in a
subsequent lecture.
This is a lot simpler notation.
And don't worry about either
the income expansion paths
or this generalization
of Slutsky.
That was meant to be a
preview of coming attractions
and motivation, not something
you should be worried
about learning right away.
So now I want to introduce
something called duality.
This looks like an
income expansion path.
As we increase income, we
get more and more points.
I think this is identical
with the figure I showed you
earlier.
But I want to use it
for a different purpose.
I want to say, suppose
we're at this point
with this intermediate
income, I2.
And we could be maximizing
utility subject to that income
level holding prices fixed.
And X2,Y2 would be the
maximum point of utility.
But suppose we did a
different experiment.
Suppose we wanted to
achieve this utility
level, U2, by spending
as little as possible.
The amount spent
would be captured
by these various
possible budget lines.
So something called a
minimizing expenditure problem,
minimal expenditure
problem, would
be to find the
budget line, which
is lowest, closest to 0,0,
and still allows the household
to get the utility level U2.
So at this point, it's clear.
You could think of this as
maximizing utility subject
to a fixed budget or
minimizing the expenses to get
to a fixed level of utility.
Both things are true and,
you can go back and forth.
And that is the essential
idea of duality.
OK, let's do it a bit
more with notation.
Let's take a consumer
with a consumption
set in L-dimensional
commodity space
with the preferences represented
by a continuous utility
function.
And let's look at the
Utility Maximization Problem,
UMP for short,
which is to maximize
utility subject to
being within the budget.
So this says, choose a point
in the consumption set,
all of the positive [INAUDIBLE],,
which maximizes that utility
function subject to, the points
under consideration have to be
such that, when you take
the dot product of P and X,
P1,X1 plus P2,X2, dot, dot,
dot, it cannot exceed wealth
or income.
So that's the utility
maximization problem.
The result of solving
the maximization problem
can be substituted
into utility--
in other words, utility
at the maximal solution.
And we're going to call
that the value function
or indirect utility function.
Note that the maximized utility
is a function of the parameters
or the exogenous
variables of the problem--
namely, the Price
vector, p, and Wealth, w.
Now, in contrast, the
Expenditure Minimization
Problem, EMP, is to--
given a certain
level of utility--
minimize expenditures,
the dot product P.X,
that allows you to achieve
at least that utility.
Getting more is fine.
But in most of the
figures we show,
this will be at an equality.
But just like you could
spend less than your income
in principle, here,
you could achieve
a higher level of utility.
But whatever you're doing here
in the expenditure minimization
problem, you're trying to
minimize total expenditures.
And we call the solution to
that the E for Expenditure--
minimized expenditure
at the optimum--
is a function of the parameters
of the problem, the same price
vector p.
But now what's taken as a
given is u, not w, but u.
So we'll have this notation for
value function and expenditure
functions.
Expenditure functions and
demands, for that matter,
have certain properties.
It turns out, the expenditure
function is concave,
and the derivative of the
expenditure function is demand.
So when you take the second
derivative of demand,
it picks up the concavity of
the level expenditure function.
And that's why that
Slutsky equation
holds because we're
looking at the matrix
of second-order
conditions, effectively.
But again, just ignore
me if that's confusing.
We'll get there in
that lecture 19.
For now, I just want to
focus on this relationship,
this duality.
And there's a number
of ways to put it.
The notation is
surprisingly subtle.
But if you work
through it, it's fine.
So suppose we're given a
continuous utility function
representing locally nonsatiated
preferences with a consumption
set, strictly
positive price vector.
If x* star is optimal under the
utility max problem for a given
wealth at those prices, then x*
is optimal in the expenditure
minimization problem when
the required utility level is
the utility you achieve under
the utility maximization
problem.
I showed you a picture of
that just a minute ago.
And the minimized expenditure
when you solve the EMP
is exactly the wealth that you
had in the utility maximization
problem.
Let me go back.
So I started here.
We had income I.
Prices were given.
You maximized utility, ended
up at U2, given I and P.
We had a certain optimizing
solution here called X2,Y2 that
solves the utility
maximization problem.
And then I said, what if we
fix the utility level instead
and solve the expenditure
minimization problem, which
is finding the expenditure
level earmarked by these budget
lines, which is minimal and,
yet, allows us to achieve
the utility level U2.
So this budget line, which was
a budget line for the utility
maximization problem, is kind
of the minimized expenditure
line for the expenditure
minimization problem.
I don't know.
Maybe the picture
is just easier.
But the notation says that.
And it actually
goes the other way.
If x* were solving the
expenditure minimization
problem, when the required
utility level is parameter u
then x* is also optimal--
the same x-- in the utility
maximization problem,
where we give the
guys wealth equal
to the minimized expenditure.
And when they solve the
utility maximization problem
at that level of wealth,
they end up exactly
with the u we started with in
the expenditure minimization
problem.
Relatedly-- and this is
the most compact notation
of all that's kind of cool.
Another way to state
the proposition
is to say that, given equation
3, when we start, given a price
vector p, we are
fixing prices p,
we give the guy
income or wealth, w.
We solve the utility
maximization problem.
We substitute the maximizing
demands into utility.
We get the indirect
utility function.
Now, starting with
that level of utility,
we do the expenditure
minimization problem
and the minimized
expenditures at that
the in particular utility
level is W all over again.
So it's like feeding
back to itself.
Likewise here, we start with
the parameterized level of u
in the expenditure minimization
problem, taking, again, p.
Vector p is given.
At that level u, we solve for
the minimized expenditure,
which we called e of p and u.
And if we take that minimized
expenditure and substituted it
as a wealth term and solve
the utility maximization
problem at that
wealth, we would get
that the indirect
utility is exactly
the u that we started with.
So it is a bit of a mouthful.
The notation is quite
compact, and you may just
have a white-out
moment when you see it.
But it is repeating in different
ways in related notation.
Oh, this also means that e and
v are inverses of one another
in the sense that take e and
multiply by some imagined e
inverse, and you'd get rid
of e on the left-hand side
and have an e inverse
on the right-hand side.
So you'd have the
value of function
is an inverse of v. Sorry,
I said that wrong, actually.
If you take e and get rid
of it by taking e inverse,
when you take the inverse
of the expenditure function,
you end up with
a value function.
And likewise, when you take the
inverse of the value function,
you'll end up with the
expenditure function.
OK, I said it
right at that time.
There's a question.
AUDIENCE: You keep saying
indirect utility function--
or, I guess, what do you
mean when you say indirect?
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND:
It has a label.
I mean, v looks like value.
You say, value function.
But it's called the
indirect utility function
in the literature.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ROBERT M. TOWNSEND: That's
the name that we give it.
So Hicksian Demand is solving
the expenditure minimization
problem.
And we have the Hicksian
demand or demand correspondence
if there's more
than one solution.
And then the diagram, so
there's been a unique solution.
This looks like
it's a new slide.
But actually, right
from the very beginning,
where we were talking about
price effects and income
effects, and we defined the
price effect as a substitution
effect, we were moving along
a given indifference curve.
So we were really talking about
Hicksian demands all along.
And again, for
the third time, we
have a different way
of stating the problem,
that the ordinary demand is
equal to the Hicksian demand
evaluated at a
utility level, which
is the indirect utility of the
utility maximization problem.
And likewise, for the
expenditure minimization
problem.
This is, as I've been saying,
true starting at this point.
You start looking at it
one way or the other.
You end up with
exactly the same point.
But if we start actually
taking discrete changes,
things are a bit different.
And in fact, we were actually
doing that at the beginning,
right?
We were talking about
a non-trivial decrease
in the price of X.
So let's talk about discrete
changes and compensated demand.
We start with p and w.
We have the maximized
demand, x, for that given w.
But we change p
from p to p prime.
Then w prime would, say, be
the minimized expenditure
at the level of utility,
u, the initial level
of utility at the baseline but
with the new different price
vector, p prime.
And we call that new wealth
as opposed to old wealth.
Call it w prime.
So in words, that level
of income or wealth
w prime is the one that, under
the new price vector p prime,
would minimize the expenses
at p prime of achieving
the old utility level.
Remember, when we
change the price,
we just rotate it along
the indifference curve
going one way or the other.
That's all this English and
all this notation means.
We're just compensating
the agent for the change
in purchasing power.
But of course, demand doesn't
stay constant because the new
demand, x*, will be different
as the prices are different.
And the Hicksian demand includes
the price substitution effect,
is defined by it.
So the Hicksian demand, at the
old utility level and prices p
prime, is different from the
original baseline purchase.
Anyway, if you understood the
income and substitution effects
at the beginning,
that's all this slide
is saying, where we have
nontrivial discrete changes
in the price.
Here's the picture again.
But be forewarned that, somehow,
to make it more interesting,
we're going to change the price
of good 2 instead of good 1.
And we are going to
increase the price.
So the original baseline
budget is from w to w over p2.
Why just w?
Well, there's an assumption
down here that we only
care about the price ratio.
So let's denominate everything
in units of good on the X-axis.
p1, the first good, equals 1.
So we don't need
to worry anymore
about the price of the
first good because it's 1.
And the question
is, what's the price
of the second good
relative to 1?
In this case, the price of the
second good, p2, is going up.
So you would go from w
over p2 attainable to w
over p2 prime attainable
when you go from a price p2
to p2 prime.
This is like the
earlier diagram,
where we fixed a
point on the Y-axis
and pivoted on the X-axis.
But this is the other
way around because we're
changing the price of good 2
and not the price of good 1.
OK, so we start here, and we
have an income, a lower budget
line.
Now we want to break that
into two pieces, namely
the substitution effect
and the income effect.
What is the substitution effect?
At this higher price of
p2, it's p1, over p2,
If you remember the slope.
So as p2 goes up,
that slope goes down.
So we're going to rotate
along this indifference curve
and effectively
maximize utility,
which is giving you this point.
What's the maximum
utility you can get
or the minimized expenditure?
Rotating along this
indifference curve.
And then the income effect
is moving from here,
a parallel shift back to here.
So our initial level of wealth,
w, was on this good 1 axis,
and our new level of wealth
is this minimized expenditure
at the new prices, p prime,
given utility level u.
So we've gone from w to w prime.
That's the change in
wealth in terms of good 1.
Initial wealth, new
wealth in terms of good 1,
this must therefore be
the change in wealth.
And that's the change in
wealth, which is positive,
which you may have
been wondering about,
which is necessary to compensate
the agent for the fact
that the price of
good 2 has gone up.
We have to compensate the agent
for the adverse price change
by giving him or
her more income.
And this is that
level of income.
OK, so as I keep saying, but
it's probably been more or less
an abstract
statement, I'm really
interested in real
economies, where
we have something
going on over time,
or something with the
geography, or something having
to do with uncertainty,
and gambles,
and states of the world.
So having memorized or
shown you all those figures
with some very interesting
concepts and a little bit
of data along the way,
one may, nevertheless,
walk away with the
impression that we're
talking about a
static world, where
we have rice and other goods
or potatoes and other goods.
And we're just comparing wheat
to apples as we change prices.
But no, the framework
applies to any goods,
including goods that
are earmarked by time.
So suppose we have
two time periods only.
And we'll call consumption C1--
consumption and date 1, and
C2, consumption and date 2.
And we're going to give
income as an endowment,
meaning how much income they
have in the first date, 1,
and how much income they
have in the second date, 2.
Using income is
a bit tricky here
because we used that before
in the static optimization
problem.
So think of it as money, then--
money in date 1,
money at date 2.
Now, what is the budget line?
Well, if they just
eat their money,
they would have consumption
equal to m1 and m2.
But the way this is drawn,
they don't want to do that.
They want to move in one
direction or another.
So what is this budget line?
This budget line
reflects the possibility
of giving up money tomorrow
and getting more consumption
today--
that's borrowing-- or
giving up money today
and getting more consumption
tomorrow-- that's lending.
So the slope of
this heavy blue line
represents the tradeoff
of the price of goods
today for the price of good
tomorrow, which you knew
all along but probably forgot.
Why?
Because the slope of the
budget line is p1 over p2--
p1 being consumption
at date one, p2
to being-- sorry-- the price
of consumption at date two.
But the economics of the problem
doesn't write p1 over p2.
It writes r as an interest rate.
Why is it the interest rate?
Because if you gave up
some of your money today
and put it in the bank,
you would get the principal
and interest back tomorrow.
So 1 plus r, which is also
the slope of this line,
reflects the tradeoff
between consumption today
and consumption tomorrow as made
possible by this interest rate.
So then, as per
the entire lecture,
we try to change a price.
Over here, let's increase
the interest rate.
So it's still possible to eat
your money in both periods.
But now that the interest
rate has gone up,
the budget line is steeper.
For a given surrendering
of one unit of consumption
today, you get a higher
1 plus r tomorrow.
So this paler blue line crosses
through the endowment point,
but it's steeper.
And as drawn with these
indifference curves,
the household would move from
this point to this point.
So let's talk about income
and substitution effects.
Consumption, tomorrow, at
date 2, goes up and up.
Why?
Two effects, and they're both
moving in the same direction.
The increase in
the interest rate
effectively means
they have more income.
They can take their
endowment of money tomorrow,
and it will be worth more.
So there's an income
effect associated
with the price change.
Not only that, there's
a substitution effect.
Why?
Because as the
interest rate goes up,
the opportunity cost of
eating today goes up.
It's more painful to eat
today because you could
get even more tomorrow by
putting the money in the bank
at a higher interest rate.
So the substitution
effect moves them
with these nice,
smooth indifference
curves away from
consumption today
toward higher
consumption tomorrow.
So the income and substitution
effects in this diagram
work in the same
direction for good 2,
but it's not true
for good 1 at date 1.
Or at least, it
could be ambiguous.
Why?
There's an income effect, which
should increase consumption
at date 1.
But there's a price
effect, which should
decrease consumption at date 1.
And those can, in principle,
move in opposite directions.
In this case, date 1
consumption is going down,
so the substitution effect is
dominating the income effect.
But it didn't have
to go that way.
You could have drawn
the indifference curves
and gotten an increase in
the consumption of date
of that good.
OK, let's start out with a
different but related diagram.
Suppose they have money today
and tomorrow as endowments.
And this guy is
actually doing what?
Originally, borrowing,
getting more consumption today
than the money he or she has
at the expense of paying it
back with interest
tomorrow, therefore
having less consumption than the
money that he or she originally
had.
So we'd end up
with this tangency.
And now we still increase
the interest rate.
That makes this pale
blue line steeper.
And you can see consumption
is moving inwards.
So actually, consumption of
both goods in the diagram
is going down.
But let's think about income
and substitution effects.
Because they were
borrowing originally,
as opposed to
lending, intuitively,
an increase in the interest rate
is a bad situation for them.
They were borrowing, and now
the interest rate is higher.
So the income
effect is negative.
And that could show
up with both goods.
On the other hand, the
substitution effect
should still push them in the
direction of higher consumption
tomorrow.
That's the substitution effect.
So for one of these
goods, consumption today
is unambiguous.
But consumption
tomorrow is ambiguous,
despite the way it's
drawn, because the income
and substitution effects work
in the opposite direction.
So take a look at those.
There's a lot going on.
In fact, that's
kind of the point,
that when we move
from apples, wheats,
and so on with prices and
income to an applied problem,
like what's happening in
the US with these lower
and lower interest
rates, well, if we
look at consumer behavior,
there's income effects.
There's substitution effects.
You can go in different
directions and be in conflict.
And that's an important part
of understanding the impact
on the households and the
impact on the economy.
And it's actually
a lot more work
to go through this slide
and the previous one
than you might
have imagined, even
though, say, you
were totally sure you
could shift these curves around
in whatever way you wanted.
When we get to the
economic application,
we kind of do it all over again
with the new realistic labels.
And it brings that tool to life.
OK, well, that's the
last slide for today.
That's the end of this lecture.
All right, thank you very much.